there's a story on Tik Tok about the
blue houses in Hawaii that didn't burn
down because this certain kind of blue
paint won't burn and like opra painted
her roof blue like months before it
happened did Oprah say why she painted
her house blue well there's a bunch of
celebrities that painted their house
blue you do not know what blue items did
burn and are not visible to you as
having survived the fire correct yeah
you're looking at what survived it
assuming all blue survived it well I
just like to believe
things I'm not a scientist okay I'm
pretty into believing things too okay so
it's more fun and it makes headlines I
get it but I'm not that into believing
global
warming